hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Emily is way too now this
is the official sequel to emily is away
and with it comes probably a whole bunch
of heartbreak and a lot of things that
are gonna be very sad oh okay
ah alright I'll do it I did it it's my
background now I don't look good that
did but okay there we go
ah hello okay alright okay
so if you remember Emily's away you
remember that it was a conversation with
Emily and guiding through this lifetime
of talking with Emily and with it came a
lot of heartbreak Emily who is Emily my
mother would say she's everyone every
girl every boy every person that anyone
has ever loved is that more of like a
kind of like metaphysical wave talking
about who Emily is oh this is classic
before senior year Thursday August 3rd
2006 oh okay all right
markiplier mark okay oh yay unlocked an
icon oh look at me I'm so handsome oh
okay
ooh personal profile Chamillionaire
arctic monkey against me I don't know
what any of this I bet think you look
good on the dancefloor don't know if
you're looking for romance or V for
Vendetta people shouldn't be afraid of
their governments is this what people do
oh don't be normal okay alright then hey
punk forever yo mark hello everybody my
name is markiplier uh-huh okay hello ha
ha
it was almost everybody hello Evelyn
how's it going what's up Papa just
talking to people
[Music]
is it gonna turn sad yet her is it gonna
be like a slow building oh yeah I forgot
I gotta do that I'm just talking to Pete
how about you just chilling about to
paint my nails all that's so cool and
interesting I can't decide what color
though uh I believe in you
if there's one thing that markiplier
says it's I believe in oh you can do it
I believe in you all right
decide for yourself because Who am I to
tell you what to do oh but it's such a
struggle see speaking of colors I like
your new scheme spend a lot of time on
it like a lot you know I did spend a lot
of time picking it yeah I like to spend
a lot of time making decisions or such
so how's your summer going Oh
waring it's been kind of boring nothing
happening around here no what's going on
I'm sorry what have you been up to video
games a whole lot of games
awesomesauce thanks I can't believe we
go back to school in a month
Oh school sucks
it's for nerds I know high school sucks
bro let's see
[ __ ] you Ben Franklin well that's that's
mean truth at least history last year
wasn't bad let's see I cheated so much I
cheated like way too much Lowell same
funny how we never really talked before
that you still have to hang out with me
and my friends sometime oh definitely
I am a social butterfly man be awesome
got any big plans for the rest of summer
ah partay oh hell yeah
probably some epic end of summer parties
how about you owe me my friends are
driving up to Warped her on Saturday ooh
what's Warped Tour I don't know oh it's
punk rock music festival yeah what's
your favorite kind of music
I don't realize it whatever you like I
like alternative huh almost Punk but not
quite okay we've I guess Evelyn will
remember that oh no a punk rock so good
vous NC ah
I like some of it I'm pretty open to a
lot of things there's there's a lot of
going on with that hey I like some of it
fair enough
I'm JK haha I can't wait to see Senses
Fail do you know them
nope not at all why would I lie I don't
think so
never lied to you ever here listen to
this oh okay
ooh YouTube existed back then oh it's a
thing I love the big others fake like
completely fake YouTube's going on it
was this hello ah music oh hell yeah
more stats oh [ __ ] yeah bruh Numa Numa
oh it's old YouTube Oh Numa Numa that
was [ __ ] amazing it was great I love
that and I love your taste in music oh
yes you're the best it's official I know
I'm aware it's my favorite song by them
I've got the lyrics in my budding phone
speaking of infos I don't think I've
looked at yours it's amazing oh it's the
best the best bio you've ever seen in
your life
oh yeah look at it
Oh Arctic Monkeys they're okay
oh whatever okay man I don't know where
my friends are they were supposed to
pick me up like half an hour ago
probably dead yeah I don't think so I'm
sorry well I'm sorry that really sucks
but I'm here for you I'm always here
anytime you need it I'm sure they're
still coming we're supposed to go to my
friend's house in Party let's see and
leave me what you're going to leave me
whoa oh no my heart is broken
don't you worry I got my phony I should
probably start getting some stuff
together let's see let's see not coming
back tonight
oh I'm sad whoa
I don't know I might stay over at
Jackie's we'll see oh I should bring a
movie want to help me pick let's see ah
yes please it's my favorite thing we do
I love making choices for you to have
fun with other people
final destination 3 or the descent Oh
God final destination help yeah spirit
gold that's like pure pure bronze but
it's ok I know right it's so bad it's
good let's see I hope they make another
one Oh God I hope I can only hope yeah I
bet final destination for will be a
murderer what movies are your favorite
Oh horror poor all the way I guess
Evelyn will remember them ah yo mine too
we should watch them together at some
point I'd I'd like that along with my
brain I would enjoy that that's great
please yes hey just got a text they'll
be here soon
let's see whoa who's going any guys
wouldn't be too happy about going with
you Oh what was that
oh he's a tap Kido ok
hey howdy howdy neighbor
oh Emily what oh that's weird uh just
talking to people you whoa is that the
Emily let's see
sorry detecting than that a Steve Jackie
and Nate are picking me up
they're late because Steve had to get
the alcohol let's see
good job save plenty Oh Steve what a
good guy that Steve oh talking to people
- oh this good so did you do anything
funny today games why ox games lots of
games
oh he's weird I know right clutch work
I'm juggling he's only 20 but he's got a
fake ID
oh what a badass oh I wish I had one so
I could be cool and impressive oh oh
cool beams I play games like all this
morning too
and say should have played together yeah
what do you play
whoa wait for that response his friend
makes them I'll give him your screen
name oh oh yeah
Wow they ended up with a lot I see some
drunk text in my future let's see I want
some drama text me give me I'm desperate
for attention please huh The Sims soo
I'm like addicted to that game hope you
guys can follow along with its jumping
back and forth oh pretty solid choice
oh sorry Greg Oh be careful what you
wish for
uh-huh ah this weekend should be fun but
my friends are ditching me next weekend
let's see oh wow
well your friends screw them oh really
I'm just a sucker for any RPGs game
what's a games your favorite Oh back in
2006 I played so many mmo's personally I
really like MMO games
oh yeah Mele you will remember don't you
oh hey they're going on a road trip and
my mom won't let me go I need plans uh
we could do something we could do
something together no to get maybe chill
and listen to music you sure hey you
want chill no chill like wow don't you
have to pay for those any month every
month let's see ah yeah but we could
play together it's not bad and we could
play together yeah like friends you'd
like that
yeah maybe hang out like just us uh yeah
just us
yeah just what whatever you want come on
put some spine in your backbone oh yeah
oh that does sound like it could be fun
so that was my morning then I just hung
out Jeff's Jeff's house that J Radio 49
Oh was that my character from the
beginning mm-hmm
what is he gonna I don't know really not
in the same music right well we could
get a group together and do something
else
oh come on just lose I like alternative
okay I gas off yeah okay I guess let me
know yeah yeah [ __ ] off it is ha ha give
buddy got super boring so I left
ah boring boring that sucks why was it
boring
oh yeah just finish packing I'm gonna
head out inebriated Texan coming on
deuces deuces or douches what the [ __ ]
hey don't question me I'm cool okay fine
he was just doing his own thing the
whole time whatever I'd rather be home
talking to people anyways let's see
people like me yeah I'm cool I'm cool
right yeah I'm cool I was thinking the
other day well it's pretty crazy our
group of friends that stay together like
all of high-school friends mm-hmm I know
don't ask me how oh who knows honestly
who in the world knows I wonder have
senior year is gonna change that let's
see I don't know you never know
I guess we'll say the future is nebulous
no one knows yeah I don't know people
have already started act differently
let's say friends okay of course of
course with some friends I wouldn't be
good it would suck to lose you
oh I know I'm great
hey do you know the band Snow Patrol Oh
chasing cars I have that song code I
know them oh I know them oh no oh yeah
but the key radio kind of murdered that
one yeah here's another one of their new
album it's my favorite oh yes please oh
let's see what's up here um oh yeah
that's good oh that's nice and
copyrighted I'll [ __ ] yeah oh give me
some of that oh that's great oh I love
that thank you thank you for getting me
a copyright strike oh I like this oh I
like I like this a lot
oh god yeah this is right at my style
isn't it grand the music video is really
cool too oh where was it shot oh look
still
come on hey cool Paris I think it's so
gorgeous yeah I want to see them live so
bad but like no bands ever play around
here ah man that's so true
that sultry all we get is like Warped
Tour Oh
oh yeah that's like the punk music
festival right do you know anyone that
goes there oh yeah some friends no my
friends are going [ __ ] losers ball oh
yeah I don't think I know anyone that's
going what's your favorite kind of music
Oh alternative definitely alternative oh
Emily
it's alternative oh my god me too you're
seriously the best huh oh she not no
bond oh [ __ ] girl oh I know I know the
best oh hell yeah hey you finally set up
your buddy info Arctic Monkeys lyrics
they're in my info too who'da thunk tit
would you look at that hey would you
look at them we're like two peas in a
pod Emily so you're like my favorite
person right now oh you're not so bad
yourself ah shucks aw shucks here me and
Emily me and Emily we're on the same
page oh yeah who's that who's there
who's there quick I need your help
coming up with good excuse
let's see your dog ate it I'm on the job
that's it always works I got it oh I
don't know about that
Jeff wants to hang out this weekend with
Oh with his friends this weekend but I
really don't want to let's see
stupid Jeff why not Oh Julian hmm
hanging out with his friends just means
sitting around getting drunk I think
Jeff's friends and Punk for Eva's
friends are similar and I don't really
drink so I don't know let's see doesn't
sound like fun hmm
yeah that doesn't sound like a lot of
fun and you know who else is fun of this
guy this guy's pretty far I'm pretty fun
yeah do you drink Marc no actually I do
not
nope I don't know I never drink I can't
I'll die yeah whatever
cool beans we're in the same boat yeah I
know weird huh why don't you drink yeah
man it's unhealthy for me cuz I'll die
you know I'll literally die do you do it
if really is I feel the same E oh yeah
so I just panicked and I said I already
had plans ah the old scheduling conflict
I see how you do that's real nice I like
it I'm with it I'm hip um now I just
need to find some plans for tomorrow
hang on with me get a on me we got out
we could play some games together was
this music not bring have cool times
maybe should we invite other people
author other people other people suck I
don't really carry oh come on spine oh
come on whatever I guess we like
different kinds of games anyway oh Emily
come on now so maybe we should invite
some people and figure it out let's see
Oh sound good whatever - yeah cool I'll
talk to you about tomorrow Oh hit me up
on the flippity-flop yeah oh wow it's
getting kind of late huh
oh I guess it is yeah I guess it is ours
just passed by talking to you I think
I'm gonna add to bed a deuces yeah yes
Oh deuces and the magic trick all deuces
deuces press the button in the lower
left to sign out okay fine way I go Oh
what that was it
oh that was chapter one oh well that was
beautiful
I guess oh god do I want to go through
this if there is no love in the world we
will make a new world we will give it
walls and a knocker that resonates so
softly that we will never hear it well I
guess that's it then so I I guess I can
do another chapter that one by pretty
quickly I can Oh God
it's October the 13th I mean it's Friday
the 13th that's more that's more scary
than the other one was but I can do
another one that one button by pretty
quickly
mostly [ __ ] because I know what I'm
doing here hugs hugs I'm just gonna
stick with mine let's see uh Snow Patrol
take my hand okay ah bork Borat all the
departed
I like the department I actually can't
watch the bore at the the like the I
don't like um cringe humor it's just
weird to me I don't want to be a product
of my environment I want my environment
to be a product of me okay sure
the best is yet to come oh yeah hey yo
Dawg what is up what is it my dog uh
Evelyn say hey Mark what's up ah
listening to some sweet tunes you hey
Mark how is you
oh man pretty tired from all this
working out and I've been doing getting
pumped up with my muscles Oh
Seimei do you know what today is Oh
Frawley ferric Center
[ __ ] is a leaf every day not too much
got home from Kelly's a little while ago
I do not know if you guys can keep up
with this but I'm gonna do it
Oh what you to do why wasn't I invited
Oh what is up
oh it's Friday the 13th oh good thing
we're not counselor was oh [ __ ] my mom's
calling me for dinner but I'll be on
later talk to you then
Oh baby okay see you I'll see you later
you have fun eating dinner deuces
bye okay well pretty much Oh what are
you gonna do to celebrate Oh
black oh shut your eyes I'll spin the
picture okay Joe samesies okay sure
whatever I'm so happy it's fall it's
like my favorite season oh god it
actually gives my favorite season
another fault I love that leaves
changing the winter Oh God are you gonna
dress up for Halloween never too old
hell yeah oh hell yeah why wouldn't I
wouldn't I come on
what do you even don't even saying
awesomesauce me to Jackies having a big
Halloween party I'm looking at costumes
now what do you think I should go as
shoes Oh God hello dad I went as a sexy
nurse for Allah when once it was awesome
well you wish yeah I just said I wished
come on I was actually trying to decide
between Alice and wonderland and Sally
from Nightmare Before Christmas hmm I'll
look at this ah nice oh that's good
stone oh I gotta go with Sally I
actually do oh yeah I gotta go with
Sally Oh
Sally I think I like the Sally costume
the most we're really primo there that's
what I was thinking I'll go pick it up
tomorrow
yeah well that I could help Jackie's
parties are always crazy you can
probably expect more drunks text oh yeah
oh lucky me
let's try to spell better this time come
on I think I still have some of those
locked on my phone from this summer I
don't know how you understand
any of them I see I'm that good
also you save those that's interesting
I'm sorry though low like this one oh
hell yeah lay it on me what you got I'm
ready
oh my god we think Jackie's roof by now
and starts never flooded so bootiful ah
think Jackie's roof fine now and starts
never flooded so beautiful ah we are on
Jackie's roof right now and stars never
look stars never look so beautiful I got
it
I know I decide for my mom's sex all the
time my mom's texts are crazy but it's
I'm not intentionally hilarious
you got it damn I'm impressed Laura hey
maybe you could just come to the party
do you drink oh no I don't actually do
not I'll die I can't live as literally
will die no I don't like drinking oh
cool cool that's probably smart yeah cuz
the whole I'll die thing do you like
care of people around your disc drinking
say of course not
Oh drink all you want drink one for me
people gonna do whatever oh yeah
I just will die I'll literally die you
should totally come out and party then
oh [ __ ] yeah I'll count me the [ __ ] in
Oh count me in baby oak oh yeah I'm a
partier mhm
the only rule is you have to dress up
what do you want to go as oh could I be
a Jack Skellington
maybe I'll go is Jack Skellington or
something yeah oh yeah that'd be awesome
sauce we'll take some pictures I'll add
you to the event page [ __ ] oh yeah oh
wait are we friends on Facebook oh we
should be well yeah oh friend me up baby
then friend me when you get a chance yo
Oh Sam no oh hell yeah already doing it
I'm on it
100% oh I'm here oh what's this a dad's
friend oh [ __ ] yeah oh give me some of
that oh what's going on here hanging
with France in City night before
Christmas Harry Potter Obama
note oh oh my god okay man it's weird
these people are all the exact same age
as I am I was born June 28 1989 this is
super weird because it is exactly my age
group which is super [ __ ] weird ah I
read your survey note it was super weird
there's read your survey another thing
don't know what it is but I read it oh
no now you know my darkest secrets so
what are you up to see black magic oh
[ __ ] that's right what sort of black
magic oh you know the standard stuff
what are you up to yeah you know you
know standard just listening to music
okay Senses Fail just came out with a
new item
oh is it any good yes I don't know what
that is but I'm asking mhm it's all the
good oh so good oh I'm gonna listen to
this and I'm gonna love it
wow that was great okay cool glad I did
that can see this song and the next one
are my favorite
Oh awesome sauce oh this is this is the
sauce of awesome oh [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah I'm so glad you like the same music
as me yeah my tastes have changed
seriously you're pretty swell oh you're
swell to god you're so swell you're so
small I really like talking to you see I
like it too hey yeah I sent a smiley you
know what that means I'm really glad we
sat next to each other in history last
year lol
although I feel like there's a lot about
you I still don't know Oh ask me
anything
I'm a red am a come on me too I have an
idea let's play a game
I hope it's truth or dare I get to ask
you a question whatever then you get to
ask a question Oh sounds fun okay I'm
ready for this whatever this means and
just ask what comes to mind first if it
takes too long it'll just mean my turn
again okay are you ready born ready
yeah whatever what up what up bring it
on I'll start with an easy one do you
remember my favorite kind of movie up
core or a little ooh
yup
I knew you'd remember oh yeah oh yeah
you didn't know now it's your turn quick
ask me anything ah favorite color blam
what's your favorite color black is the
objectively correct answer let's see
have you ever snuck out of your house oh
yeah times you're there to go hang out
with friends and stuff I've snuck out
exactly one time in my life oh sure I
know your turn again let's see ah same
question yeah how many times more times
than you can count
snuck out oh yeah I just did this past
weekend alright let's get serious
do you have a crush on anyone yeah I do
Oh Oh total ooh yeah oh oh yeah a
scandalous wonder who it is oh I know
what I'm asking next let's see do you
have feelings for anyone and if yes ooh
oh that's two questions I'm cheating
here unfair that's like two questions
let's see oh it's one and a half at most
oh please come on now oh you're a
cheater but I'll answer both feelings I
don't know maybe it's kind of
complemented in a good way yeah I can be
good kind of complicated that that's an
option I'm okay no no me and this person
have history together
Oh like the class history oh yeah it's
not me is it no me no like a
relationship
Oh Oh Steve Myers you know him right
Oh fake ID guy yo-yo okay yeah me and
him dated for a lot of my sophomore and
junior year he got pretty serious and I
definitely think I loved him well Vanny
got off to college so it broke up with
me last winter
oh okay I'm so sad
oh yeah it's more just confusing than
anything like I'm getting over him it's
just weird
Lowell are you off and on hmm no
definitely not okay it's just that the
feelings still hang around when it
worked we were really good couple
mm did he love you that is a good
question hmm yeah I think he did well
what did you never say like who's the
first person I ever had sex with hmm
let's see relationships end sim you
moved on good question
I mean I had a like a fling this past
summer but nothing serious is Steve
obviously let's see uh Flynn what kind
of fling the flingy fling one-night
stand
not even like a relationship hmm we
fooled around but like it was fun not
serious you know hmm
mark if you don't mind me asking have
you ever had sex I know all about the
sex Oh kind of it's a little bit like
halfway I've had a half a sex you know I
didn't want to commit to the full 100 oh
yeah oh yeah I have oh yeah that's what
I thought
so you understand what I mean mmm lost
versus loved and all that yeah I'm an
old sage when it comes to love and and
the matters that it does contain not a
lot of people know but me and Steve had
these plans for our future
so being together felt like a big deal
hmm what kind of plans I'm listening
intensely it's gonna sound really stupid
don't judge me okay oh oh no judgement
here I would never even dream of it
so I thought we
go to the same college together mmm and
then maybe I don't know get married
start a family whatever let's see I mean
sounds normal
it's not wrong to warn something hmm so
you thought you had like a literate
future with Steve here it's just real
silly now thinking about it but I think
that's why it's been hard to get over
the break-up let's see would you go back
to them the answer is obviously yes like
obviously yes definitely not even
without Steve I think I still want that
future but maybe that's silly let's see
that's not silly at all and that future
is still definitely a reach but uh
saying she still has a hold on for
Steven I just think people think it's
stupid when I talk about it see I don't
think it you can do whatever you want
you free thanks mark you've really made
me feel a lot better I know see what are
your pans after college do you want a
family yeah yeah definitely settling
down sounds pretty good you know hard to
be a youtuber that's cool too right I'm
so glad you don't think it's weird I
feel like it sounds silly when I talk
about it oh no it's not weird at all
perfectly normal
very normal thanks so much for letting
me rant about this oh you got it you got
it hey I just remembered it's still my
turn to ask you a question
Lowell okay sure all right okay last one
though last one you're getting a little
uppity about this here is a good one
would you ever date someone like me oh
definitely pretty squirrel yeah you're
pretty swell God nice swelling going on
oh you're swell I know I'm swell I'm
swell your turn
last question don't [ __ ] it up let's see
would you ever date me are you gonna not
bail oh god damn it yo what were you
gonna say I say you delete some [ __ ]
would you date me you ever date someone
like me
come on now horror movies are your
favorite we're both pretty mature I
think and we have the same life plan oh
oh yeah oh yeah so yeah I can see that
happening
oh oh oh hell yeah
oh man sounds good
winky face oh yeah oh yeah [ __ ] I know
let's give each other code rose you
first want one oh yeah god I love code
can I be eagle one can you be eagle -
yeah what should i what should it be ah
Eagle One oh come on Eagle One Eagle One
Eagle One I like that name alright my
turn
don't pick a [ __ ] one ah Eva Eva ah
Evy
I don't uh you Eevee iLike Eevee a lot
hey me too good choice Hey okay I got it
oh wow it's getting late huh alright and
I still want a shower before bed shower
like naked
you mean like shower like I seen naked
oh just checking hey me too
hey no I mean - ah shower naked all the
time it's great
Oh what do you know yeah it's pretty
good pretty good
I'm gonna go but tonight was really fun
hey should do this again check and on
the Internet it's cool good night Eagle
One oh you good night Eevee hmm good
night
alright good night I sent there's
something in the wind that feels like
tragedies at hand okay oh oh it's Emily
oh Emily Haise worry about that oh you
love me I can't believe you just leave
me like them I can't believe it a
you're fine so what were we talking
about oh I don't know shower and naked
O'Kelly's yeah she showed me the set on
Facebook you do you know it let's see ah
what were we talking about on Facebook
oh yeah I know it
oh yeah I have a profile and there's
pictures on it and whatnot
oh cool and set mine up now this is so
many questions
Oh questions like what don't get any
wrong it'll ruin your seat sure ruin it
Oh No okay last part I have to write ask
is what should I write Emily is talking
to mark Emily is the last Emily is the
best oh that's definitely what I should
use mmm there it's finally done I'll
send via a link Ealing
winky link so be a Winky Dink
coming fun of it I would never dream of
it not on your life Emily let's see all
right hang on I'm gonna poke you add as
friend wink ooh yeah man you filled this
out quick Kelly told me to do this ah
okay
all right oh it's one of those surveys I
poked you did you like that was it good
okay I'm gonna poke you I'm gonna poke
you so much but poke that it's poking
even still ring on Facebook yeah the
poke war is own yeah it is you should
send me a friend request when you get
the chance
oh [ __ ] yeah already did it ah if you're
lucky
ah are you up to I already sent a friend
request he's gonna say in prize stay up
late if seeing is believing
oh okay dorri I'm still here oh let's
see
showing off your away message oh yeah
oooh Jew radio
oh yeah that's definitely it I just
don't want to talk to some people do I
have to Oh
have to use my muscles to lay the
smackdown on someone hawk
no Geoff's is kind of being an ass Oh
what happened hmm
just some [ __ ] I don't know maybe
I'm being [ __ ] tonight or something so
you're never [ __ ]
you're never [ __ ] what do you say I
can send you the chat log yeah sure okay
just don't show anyone okay that's it I
promise
of course I promise up I would never
show a lot of people on the internet
this okay except I'll transfer all good
the blazing speed [ __ ] you okay what do
we got here hang on let me get this hey
Emily what's up not much nothing much
when you coming over I don't know if a
gang got a lot of homework you can just
do it here it's kind of like project
stuff I really don't think I can come oh
come on Emily we've had this plan all
week I know I'm sorry you're not gonna
come over I had the whole night planned
I don't think I can holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
are you serious
what the [ __ ] Emily look I'm sorry I
told you that it might not work out I
didn't think you were [ __ ] serious
well I was I really can't believe you
think I'm gonna go sure
whatever whatever okay he's kind of a
dick I did yeah I got it all right yeah
yo yeah I got that yeah I did I don't
know do you think I was out of line
definitely not that guy's a giant brick
to be able to do whatever you want guys
an [ __ ] yeah I just don't want to go
over tonight sometimes it's just hard
being there oh that's that's not good
why is it hard
why is it hard I just feel like I'm
expected to act a certain way when I'm
there and a hatred the problem solved
though because I can just fake being
away and talk to you yeah I'm always
here for you just know that I'm always
here for you
oh we're here thanks mark thanks thanks
random question do you remember my
favorite game up
RPGs oh yeah of course I know
oh yeah I'm crazy yeah you should be
oh you should be you remember my room
and I'll always baby Oh rose
oh you're good oh you're oh you're
pretty good ah we're good
oh you and I we're good oh yeah we're
good okay hey listen to some sugar
Ross together Oh dice oh god I know them
they're so good oh yeah
aren't they I really love this album oh
[ __ ] yeah send them Oh God
I'll let me get let me get up let me get
up let me get a load of that oh [ __ ]
yeah that was great
oh my god that was so good oh Emily you
were this is great oh this is great ah
[ __ ] you yeah let's listen to the album
together I have no idea what the lyrics
mean but their music always makes me
feel so happy oh let's go to Iceland now
we need to go to Iceland alright how
about tomorrow
sure hey cool beans you put snow patrol
lyrics in your info I really like them
oh yeah really like them oh you know me
yeah me too we're the same you have some
pretty good taste in music Zoo oh so do
you
oops this is compliment each other until
the end of our days oh yeah baby start
applying to college yeah I started
applying this summer yeah oh wow you're
on the ball I haven't started you were
you looking to going oh you know close
far far far away how about you
oh wait four actually I would if I could
far away - I'd really love to go to
school in the city mm-hmm
Lindsay and I've always thought it would
be really cool to live in New York oh my
god that would be so Bradish actually
all you did want to go to New York I
want to live there for just like a
little bit of time I think that'd be
really cool
haha right I think I really would just
want to get out of here and go someplace
totally new you know oh I feel the same
I love new things I actually do do you
want to stay in New York after college
like I love new experiences I'm just
trying to find new things yeah I think
it could be really grand
mm-hmm but I don't know planning that
far out can be a little silly oh oh oh
oh so much could change so much could
change the weather life traffic and I
really don't see myself settling down
anytime soon like right now I honestly
don't even see myself having kids and
see oh adoption what about adoption
that's all it's an option adoption the
option adoption oh it's not bad I just
don't see myself wanting a family Oh see
I just want to be able to take life as
it comes I think mmm wild and free wild
free mm-hmm ah something like that it
does seem like Emily mm-hmm how about
you after college do you want to settle
down like right after I see ah oh this
would be contrary information but you
know I don't think so taking life as it
comes sounds pretty good to me you know
whatever if it happens it happens I'm so
glad you think the way same way I do
if you move to New York maybe we'll be
roommates let's see I'd like that oh I'd
like that it'd be a blast we'd have a
blasty blast
we'd be blasting all night long it would
be thanks for letting me talk about it
whenever I talk about New York with Jeff
he always gets so upset Liz he he wants
what he wants to settle down or
something
[Music]
yeah I guess so it doesn't want me to go
far away but I think he knows I'd go
without him ah do you even like him
don't take this the wrong way but you
even like him you know I'm just asking
I'm just trying to be yeah I do he's
going through a really tough time he
just wants to be a more serious couple
hmm do you want that do you want to be
more serious
mmm this is pretty personal you can't
tell anyone
Oh swear to God Oh twice we won't say it
things we're good
I swear swear it up swear it up and down
up and down an all around town I swear
me and Jeff haven't had sex I think you
wanted to try to night or something his
parents are at home ah do you want to
well we want to it's a plain and simple
question
no I think I'm just not ready for that
with him but it's okay it's not like
he's ever tried anything it's just kind
of annoying to keep turning him down
oh just be careful yeah oh wait until
you're ready just wait until you're
ready it's okay to not want yeah but
sometimes I feel weird like I should
have done it by now oh you're not weird
oh you're definitely not weird it's your
relief you do that me I'm an expert on
it I'm an expert ask away I know the
questions coming come on ask me recipe
you don't mind oh there it is okay yeah
yeah I have yeah I have
I don't sorry I'm just a sex god you
know oh no cool well thanks for talking
to me about it oh I'll always be here
for you every Emily huh thanks always
I'll always be here I'm sorry I saw a
stole so much for you tonight just
talking about random stuff Oh
nice but nice serious heart-to-heart
oh hi Kel bells mm-hmm yeah it has been
I really like talking to you about stuff
oh thanks I know I feel like we're
different now but in a good way oh yeah
oh I'd uh I don't I don't know what we
are uh yeah yeah we're different to
feeling really different you and I but
just weird
can I ask you kind of a personal
questions of course of course
why aren't you in a relationship Oh
haven't made a move yet haven't made a
move you know what I mean you just seem
like such a great catch
Oh could there be on us you think there
could ever be like on us I mean from my
perspective you have you've been in
serious relationships and I have but
alternative music is your favorite we
have the same outlook on life like if I
was single ha ha ha ha
you're just a really great person okay
you should know that see you're great
too Emily you're great you creatively
great I like when you use my name oh ho
ho I think we should figure out a
nickname Oh M um how about I am Sam okay
mm I like it
yay okay do you want me to call you
something Oh Oh only if I get to choose
it ah [ __ ] yeah call me eagle one baby
bonny Eagle one Oh [ __ ] Eagle Eagle -
Oh [ __ ] Eagle - forev illegal one for
Evelyn oh [ __ ] eagle to call the eagle -
baby call me eagle - it suits you I like
I know I know what's up oh man I think I
need to get off the computer right now
oh no why oh why my mom needs a look at
the emails or something Oh on this
I miss you I miss you too
Oh thanks again for everything tonight
hey deuces baby Oh
deuces anytime anytime day or night I'll
be slinging it all night long
talk to you again soon ah oh you better
oh you better or if you don't walk me
[ __ ] ow
I'll purpose oh okay well I did that Wow
okay so anyway that is the first two
chapters of Emily is way too there's
three more chapters to go so I think I'm
gonna finish it up in just a little bit
later winter is coming
for a hurricane or burning building I'd
rather die terrified than live forever
and I like this game because I can
answer honestly and still like feel like
I'm making some serious progress in the
game but I just know my heart's gonna
get broken no matter what I do because
there's two different girls here and I
can't win both they're arts and then
blabbity blabbity life so I don't know
but either way thank you everybody so
much for watching I will play more this
in the near future and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]